[Musica]
da tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fatti j
oggi siamo su scrive l'on a me avrei
detto ragazzi che non so quanto possa
essere uguale al precedente perché
allora scrive l'anm est come potete
vedere dal menu principale parla di più
famosi eroi che esistono cd con superman
batman per dirne due che vedete anche
nello schermo
comunque visto che non in italy che
cazzo sia cioè come si sa che impedirà
iniziare subito perché sono curiosissimo
avevo fatto un file ago mancato il tasto
va bene cosa ci vuole per essere nero e
ci vuole farvi gertz no velocità ma
figurati se quello il motivo di
affrontare le paure amico mi ha senso di
giustizia
ci vogliono due cuffie e dormi si può
costruire un eroe ma guarda magari con i
lego può anche darsi e ne ho visto
troppo spesso se gli eroi nascono dalle
tragedie che domanda difficile cazzo
quanto quanti soldi vale
questa è la storia di un ragazzo che
avrebbe tenuto il destino di un mondo
nel lager atom a grazia maxwell air ha
sì un ragazzo come gli altri gli piaceva
giocare a volte si metteva nei guai ma
cercava sempre di fare la cosa giusta
seguire fa vj ogni giorno molti altri
ragazzi
maxwell amava i fumetti
anche a lily la sorella di max che c'era
nei fumetti piacevano anche video rifà
vj vero bisticciavano tutti i fratelli
su quale dei loro eroi preferiti fosse
il migliore anch'io con cat mario mondo
la leva decise che avrebbe scoperto di
persona chi era l'eroe più forte sì ma
si stanno mangiando vivi praticamente
maxwell e league non erano ragazzi come
gli altri
maxwell poteva creare qualsiasi oggetto
scrivendone il nome sul suo palermo
il quaderno c'è rimasto quindi è che la
portava ovunque pur esse
a gotham city perché la dams no ragazzi
aspettate cioè vogliono andare a gotham
city
perché a gotham city non l'ho capita st
coda fu così che arrivarono nel mio
mondo
qui maxwell avrebbe scoperto cosa ci
vuole per essere sei tu bruce wayne
avrebbe dovuto affrontare il suo
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] che trama è fantastico cazzo
cioè no questa è veramente una delle
introduzioni più epiche che abbia mai
visto che il caso ci fa batman già
all'inizio ragazzi c'è batman non lo so
sarà meglio che questo contratto non ho
fatto in tempo modalità invisibile
caccia piano di supereroi sto posto poi
cazzo velli lì lì lì c'è matteo mio ma
sono qui la gamba mi fa un male cane ma
riesce iniziare un cazzo di
scribblenauts senso che lily si ammazzi
in qualche modo non lo so vai da lini
perfetto ragazzi abili che i comandi me
li ricordo ancora premi per attacco ma
questa figata ragazzi non c'era
nell'altro sleigh bells accusato
quaderno mi serve un medico ci penso io
favi jaa miglior medico del mondo lo
sanno tutti perché mi danno della fava
ragazzi perché tieni st fava ragazzi è
un fagiolo di balzare penso funzioni
ugualmente me medico medico yo yo questo
mela segno e scrive noti merda dammi
ancora della pave son cazzi tuoi
trascina la tua creazione il successivo
per rimuoverlo che perfetto medico
lottano creato sai bene vedi non di non
farti pietrificare anche stavolta perché
son cazzi poi si grazie maxwell sono
stato io ma non fa niente ave lo stesso
hai visto gli storici che sono volati
via pista riti l'ho fatto io avremmo
bisogno di di batman treni di poter
andare in giro a seminare il caos no ma
ho salvato mia sorella cazzo vuoi e non
nella mia città sì ma velica al
marchisio che ti arrivano due schiaffi
anche se sei bruce wayne aspetti signor
batman siano dei bravi ragazzi proprio
come terra una pressione la cui
descrizione per risponde la sua è stata
vista aiutare joker una persona in grado
di far comparire dal nulla qualsiasi
cosa voglia non voglio correre rischi
sono batman passaggi localizzato ci
avviciniamo dance chat dell shot chi
cazzo è questo andatevene ragazzini sono
qui per onorare il mio contratto
maggio è presto detto uno dei killer più
letali del mondo e casoria faccia usa il
tuo quaderno per modificare batman con
un aggettivo amava che è già forte così
sai qualcosa che lo mette in vantaggio
a non funziona una vecchia funziona
by batman vincitutto cos'è sta vincendo
corna mi sa che non funziona ragazzi la
carne di vacca non funziona invisibile
ok
come hai fatto cioè e fa vj è tutto
merito di parigi lancia granate
stordenti fuggito per ora ok se n'è
andato senti come faccio a sapere che tu
non c'entri in una punto tutto questo
caos
ma se ti ho appena aiutato testa di
pilizia agota non ci penso io posso dare
una mano a scoprire che i responsabili
di tutto questo
se questi spariti sono davvero così
pericolosi come sostiene rintracciarli
diventa la priorità numero uno questo
non era compreso ti servirà il mio aiuto
per trovare quegli spariti batman va
bene
max ti prego sii prudente certamente
l'indice atx lo comando io non ti
preoccupare
allora può soltanto il tutto gruppo gli
ha detto anche di no bobath ma nel mio è
il mio idolo ragazzi batman il mio
[ __ ] idolo allora il commissario
gordon ha detto che ti in carica nel
trasporto di victor giusta volta il su
sas sul tetto passando dalla porta qui a
destra un agente lo aspetta per portare
a cannes city allora t rex amichevole e
anche kakà cavalcabile perfetto ci siamo
cavalca ball è perfetto allora dovremmo
riuscire a prenderlo
togliti stronzo è il mio t rex schengen
allora fermi un attimo che devo entrare
devo salire su t rex sali perfetto a
doha rosa le maniere forti ragazzi vieni
qua bastardo di matt madonna se forte
c'è esiste un t rex che cazzo se vieni
lorido ci siamo quasi
se d'origine o cazzo perché niente batte
il freddo affilato acciaio di un
coltello
amico mio non hai mai provato le banane
nell'occhio adesso ti do la
dimostrazione
va bene la sede un attimo banana
affilata barabba clicca sul bersaglio
per sparare a lanciare brutto stronzo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ho bisogno di uno strumento chirurgico
seghetto amico mio fa il tuo lavoro
oh mio dio mio dio ragazzi sarà una
scena brutti cosa fa
ma cazzo ha funzionato di brutto ma ora
che non metto in dubbio le sue doti da
medico ma rimango sempre io il medico
migliore non c'è dubbio
gli alberi contrattaccano gli alberi i
ribelli si stanno invadendo ma che cazzo
vuol dire raga l'albero spara gatti che
cazzo cane cane
vai così che cazzo succede
cioè è un'orgia ragazzi gang bang contro
i cani da parte dei gatti ci penso io a
far fuori con lo stronzo ad un albero
che gli alberi attaccassero la gente mi
è nuova comunque domandato ragazzi è
sparito l'albero non so dov'è andato a
ficcarsi non ne ho idea
cos'è c'è una macchina ragazza forse la
macchina l'auto clown di cui parlava
batman versus joker dobbiamo questa
ladro troppo fare troppo figo
ok ragazzi stiamo per iniziare una sfida
più tardi mentre caos si diffonde in
città e alberi assassini attaccano la
gente kat
giochi per ragazze troppo figo liri
vieni ho trovato l'auto clown e proprio
joker e dopo leggere con lui per questo
batman ti aveva preso per il cattivo
cazzo uguale ma da dove saltano fuori
dopo il genk e batman falli culo come si
deve joker
vediamo come se la cava con questo mi ha
[ __ ] un idea ma cazzo il t rex la mia
ragazzi ci sarà uno scontro epico e
vabbè combatterò gli t rex con i t rex
brutto stronzo lo credo di nuovo mai
così t rex la fai brutto stronzo il tuo
t rex non vale neanche la metà del mio
so che la new via da chi questo mondo lo
troveremo mai lo strike proprio mentre
mi sto divertendo così tanto con batman
non ci penso proprio
ottimo lavoro ma non attaccare
direttamente dopo il ginger ci serve
vivo se vogliamo scoprire cosa sta
succedendo ma xeno filippi gadget
d'amico e cosa più possa combattere
joker
quindi ragazzi giocherà un martello e
noi lo faremo più grosso ragazzi questo
farà la di fi così batman fargli un culo
a letto ragazzi
dalla massacrato di brutto cosa pi kim è
ok arrestatelo non esserne così certo
pipistrello ci vediamo a batman stammi
bene ragazzi è stato assurdo aiuta
batman è congelato come congelato che ne
so
falò falò vai così scongelati amico mio
grazie per l'assistenza non ti
preoccupare dovremmo prendere vivi dopo
aggiungere qualcuno dei suoi complici
se vogliamo svelare il loro piano ma
ragioniamo c'è la batcaverna prendi
quello st wright perfetto ragazzi siamo
il primo di tanti mi sa comunque ragazzi
io direi di concludere qui l'episodio
temi assolutamente sapere se volete che
lo continui perché nel caso non mi piace
dunque non lo continuo fate non sapere
nei commenti
sei video è piaciuto come al solito
lasciato argomento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come non i video
trovate nella descrizione serve siete
fuori scritti iscrivete veloci
rivediamolo prossimo vi bene ragazzi